how to become a millionaire now isn't
that the question and I mean it the
question I'm sure at some point we've
all typed this into our computer but
what I would like to ask you today is
why life is strange life is marvelous
it's extraordinary it's just not enough
right now have you felt that in fact
through social media everyone's life
these days is so extraordinary it's so
in your face reflect it so vibrantly in
comparison to your own that you start to
think enough is enough I need to step up
my game so how do you become a
millionaire firstly LIKE this video
share with your friends family anybody
who you think wants do or even needs to
hear this right now remember to
subscribe to this YouTube channel watch
the whole video if you want to know the
answer because let's be honest we all
want this answer
welcome to don't invest in property
invest in you invest in yourself the
bigger you grow the bigger your bank and
your portfolio will grow so immerse
yourself in education Jim Rohn says that
formal education will earn you a living
but self education will earn you a
fortune so read all the books read my
book if you haven't already read it buy
low rent high Rich Dad Poor Dad the
e-myth is a great business book the
richest man in Babylon fantastic around
money management secrets of millionaire
mind
there's loads of books you can immerse
yourself in there's loads of courses on
property you know I've run a two-day
property investors crash course so
immerse yourself in the education and
subjects and field of property do
whatever it takes
growing a portfolio from scratch fast is
doable but it is going to take a lot of
doing it's gonna take a lot of
discipline so if you will do what most
people are not prepared to do now then
you'll be able to do what most people
can't do in a few years time so if
you've got a drive a long way to get to
that program if you've got to get souped
up super early to attend that networking
event if you
got to live like a pauper boy you save
in order to put down some money for a
property investment then absolutely do
what you need to do I promise you you
will figure it out the information is
out there when you read the books attend
the seminars talk to the people you'll
do it also when you grow your circle
you'll be able to leverage other
people's time other people's knowledge
and also other people's money write down
your goals and tell people your goals
someone once said if you haven't written
down your goals it's not a goal it's
just a dream there's a lot of people out
there with dreams there's only a few
with actual targets but you don't want
to be a dreamer you want to be a doer
you want to be a success so write down
your goals don't be afraid to make them
quite ambitious but at the same time you
don't want it so high in the sky that
it's just not going to happen so what I
like to do is set monthly and yearly
goal so I'll say right these are what
this is want to achieve every month and
this is want to achieve my first year
once you've done that you can then
increase it and push it up push it up
push it up so when I started out in
property at 17 years old my first goal
was to just buy a house I said I want to
buy a house when I'm 18 that was my goal
I did that I said right now I want to
buy and I updated update and I am now
where I am today so I'll give you an
example rather than saying I want to be
a billionaire in ten years time you'd be
better off to say in 12 months time I
want the keys in my hand to my first
buy-to-let property and tell people that
when you sit down for your coffees after
the coffee drink they say look all I
want 12 months I want the keys in my
hands on my first house you're cheaper
so just arrived at the airport about to
go back to England Manchester really
excited to seeing my family again
and I think my number one lesson from
from this week has got to be that if you
want to be successful it's about who you
hang around with that is the biggest
thing I've learned this week hang around
successful people you will be successful
hang on a millionaire's you'll be a
millionaire hanging around with
billionaires you'll be a billionaire and
that's what has made me jump on flights
and I'm just flying back to England and
then a day after I'm going to Ireland to
meet Richard Branson so just get around
the
like people they say I'm 15 years old
how on earth am I gonna get into
property as a 15 year old teenager and
they only get into it I mean get into it
and achievement but how am I gonna
actually get rich from property starting
out as a teenager what do i mean firstly
let me just say as a teenager I think
you actually have a massive advantage
because when you're in your forties and
fifties and you've got a corporate job
you might be making 80 thousand pounds a
year for kids two cars two holidays wife
what happens is you can't have become
you enter into the rat race and you
become trapped with that because you've
got to sustain this lifestyle the Jones
is the next door and you want to keep up
with those kids that depending on you
that might be in private school so doing
anything new and pursuing and new
avenues a Kiwi risky however when you're
a teenager or young person in general
the massive advantages you got nothing
to lose you haven't even entered the rat
race yet which is a good thing because
it once you're in the rat race even if
you win the rat race you're still a rat
so I think teenage being a teenager or a
young person is not necessarily a bad
thing so how do you get into it well
here's what I would do I mean people
think it's no big deal going on a gap
year you know you're going to get me is
no big deal to spend 40 thousand pounds
on university which is gone for years
this is no big deal you know so what I
would probably do is I would drop out of
school because I don't see what the big
deal is about school anyway why would
you study hard at school with the
purpose being to get good grades that
would then give you a job and a job is
then going to give you money and put you
in the rat race like why why would you
do that so I would drop out of school
fifteen years old
I would spend three months working on a
building site that's what I would do and
I this is kind of what I did I did
sighs and why did I do that and why
would I suggest doing that any teenager
because if you work on a building site
even you're gonna get an idea of what is
doing to a house I mean ultimately if
properties create well then you've got
to understand properties and what he's
doing to make a bad property of good
quality how much does that cost and this
is all stuff that you'll learn on a
building site so I would spend the first
on that here's a challenge one year get
rich and as a teenager started with
nothing so first three months someone's
been on a building site and I were just
studying you know the craft of
plastering I did that line it up to
plaster learn how to brick lie all the
source stuff once I've done that for
three months I would then spend three
months working in an estate of an agency
again I did this I spent three months
working for countrywide I'm going in the
state agent and they negative to say
what why do that because when you're
working on this thing and I got it
working now okay I understand
the crooks in the bricks and mortar real
estate now I want to understand what
makes a good investment and why why does
that make it a good investment and when
you're working in an estate agency
you'll be finding and selling houses all
day long you'll be speaking to investors
that are saying you know they're looking
for houses and you'll get a good idea of
what a good property as an investment is
also an estate agent and alayan agents
say I've been wanting to do I wanted to
work in a bit of both because I'd also
want to know how do you find a tenant
what makes a good tenant and had what's
the process of managing that cannon what
she done that for six months along side
that I would also be reading book myself
personally
broke people poor people employee
mindset is when you trade your time for
money
rich people they don't trade that time
for money rich people they trade their
value for money and their value can be
something that they do in 20 seconds it
can be something that they do once and
the values there forever which is called
a passive income so if you're
employee and you're thinking in terms of
trading your time for money and you go
to the office and you work 9:00 to 5:00
and you get paid for 9:00 to 5:00 or if
you're an hour extra then you charge
over time for your time
you just get out of that thinking
straight away because it sucks it stinks
you'll keep you broke it will keep you
poor and rather than thinking I want to
get out of that and become my own boss
you're never gonna be your own boss
you're never gonna be your own boss
until you stop thinking like that now
consistency is key persistence is
perseverance belief an education in
yourself these things will help you
achieve what you want to achieve
[Music]